oh hey guys it's so Ryan right here
we're gonna watch the second trailer for
the judge ya heard of it oh is it that
one with Robert Downey jr. no that's
Iron Man this one does starter up or
down a junior but you were thinking of
Iron Man probably does judge people Iron
Man is very judgmental here moving
really is actually he's kind of a
narcissistic judgmental [ __ ]
yeah but we love him for that I hope you
play something similar in this movie
let's judge it ourselves good
standing in one of the last great
cathedrals in this country built on the
premise that you and you alone are
responsible for the consequences of your
actions you have anything else to say
for yourself yeah yes yeah it's not an
affirmation a man uses
but at the wake he shakes my hand or
someone else
five members of us you me Erica okay
you're just a boy from Indiana who's
gonna do whatever he has to do
perfect found traces of blood on your
dad's car it matches the victim
I made it kill somebody on your watch a
man you released you don't remember
hitting we need to establish a firm
defense are you passionate even if you
could represent me
it's fun there is a strength
and not lose this case
you put me in juvenile detention I did
what I thought was right I'll never come
back here again
you're simultaneously the most selfish
and the most generous person you know
but now a man's blood a man that you
hate was found on a car that only you
drive you didn't seize that chance and
kill it not my testimony
I'll paint your father as a
holier-than-thou prick determined to see
what he considers justice served my
father is that all there is about prick
the term to see it serve justice served
so it's gonna be a light day that's fun
that movie's gonna make me cry
I know I know I'm gonna cry Wow anything
to do with parents especially fathers I
[ __ ] ball oh you like it's going to
happen even if the movie is pure [ __ ] I
am still going to grab no I mean this
movie could have two routes it could be
really cheesy and really sappy or it
could be a really good drama when I
first heard the plot and saw the first
trailer I was like yeah it looks like
it's trying to yank it my emotions this
one looks like the performances are very
good they do they really do I honestly I
have not seen the trailer for this
before this is the first time that I'm
seeing what you know the premise is
really gonna be and it looks really
emotional but very very well done I'm
excited to see it I will see it yeah
it's a really intriguing premise it goes
beyond like father and son not getting
along you know yeah they also got like a
courtroom drama going on as well it is
pretty cool Robert Duvall like he's a
great actor and it's cool to see him
doing another performance where he's
like you know being a tough ass whole
again man
Robert Downey jr. is kind of still you
know narcissistic and a little selfish
yeah I love berr for me yeah I'm mainly
gonna see it for the acting like Billy
Bob Thornton's back in it in the drama
world again
like yeah yeah the acting just looks
really really good and I'm hoping that a
good script and good directing will back
it up exactly I think we have reviewed
the trailer I think we have not much
more we could say oh really oh yeah what
I ever told you about the time I ran
into Robert Downey jr. no I ran into
Robert you making us all you guys have
been friends and then you're like okay
Robert no I was driving down of interval
burn I was going this way and traffic
was stopped the traffic going this way
was stopped to the two cars my car in
the car next to me were exactly next to
each other and I'm sitting there I was
Spacey like I was a space case that day
and it was really hot all of my windows
were rolled down that was kind of just
staring out the window looking at the
car next to me I remember thinking like
this is a particularly shiny black
Porsche and I was just kind of observing
how shiny this Porsche looked and I
looked at the driver seat and Robert
frickin Downey jr. is doing this looking
at me
I could not process this like as soon as
the process that was like open my mouth
traffic moved that's crazy
that's Alyssa well he's married and you
shouldn't pursue that probably not what
if he met him and he was like I remember
you that would be weird
would you think he's obsessive I'd be
flattered yeah because he's a celebrity
but what if it was like just some random
guy I'd be flattered he'd still be
flattered if it was a random guy well if
it's somebody that I ran into once that
would be impressive that kind of memory
is impressive if you guys are new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you could subscribe to this is
channel where she is clearly a liar and
is gonna act like that if she just met
some random guy sure she'd be flattered
it's creepy Alyssa it's only except that
if he's a celebrity Jose Hernandez I
need mr. Ryan right shout-out please
these videos are freakin awesome so much
that was that I really don't care about
your words they don't mean anything to
me you're a horrible human being I know
but I'm also kind of generous if I get
back with shoutouts I'm trying to have a
cam I want is here where I want to be
more like Robert Downey jr. see Jose I
said that because you were nice to me
and I have a hard time just accepting
kind things I got that way
what in truth in reality I love you for
that love you but you're a dick you know
Jose in just the English enunciation is
actually Jesus the noble Lord Cornelius
edward horse big brother of shrek master
of the lord of the Thundercats my
shoutout I am waiting Ryan
okay this is gotta be a way a shorter
way to say the LCD HB s ml t d TZ no
it's you know you guys are the whole
thing I've never seen you did not walk
well I'm gonna show you out the noble
Lord Cornelius Edward horsedick brother
of Shrek master of the Lord of the
Thundercats you are a god amongst men
don't you forget that and cousins you're
a god amongst cuts not amongst men end
cuts pretty much a god amongst men and
women mainly cuts kant's not in terms of
Avena vagina as in like the person's
being a [ __ ] mm-hmm anyway you enjoy
those [ __ ] Christian white I don't make
videos but you do so give me a shout-out
please Christian Wyatt that is a great
statement yeah make some videos
Christian after all you are a
representation of our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ what do you think Christian
comes from Christ Christ II and why what
do you mean why why are you so like into
this today it's weird
into what well the there are religious
references like I've never heard you do
it as much as you're doing today
I just didn't what did one religious
reference like three one earlier you did
yeah but Christian white you are the son
of God just like all of us we're all
daughters and sons of God okay mr. white
mr. white I don't want to cook yo that's
a Breaking Bad Jesse Pinkman you know
Jesse I'm Christian white your life this
is the most random shout-out ever but
yea Christian white I know you don't
make videos like me so that means I'm a
better human being than you for
acknowledging you cuz you're part of the
little people like I said being mean out
of a defense mechanism don't really feel
that way
you need to work on your people skills
you need to work on [ __ ] the shut up